we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p
now uh many of you will be familiar with
today's caller today's caller is the san
antonio troll the san antonio troll is
known to me and probably to some of you
for calling in
and delivering blistering criticism
directed at me
for things i never said
and that's exactly what he does today
typical of the san antonio troll
you know pac-man i watched your coverage
of the state of the union and
i just can't
i you progressives are the most
out-of-touch people
on the freaking planet okay and what's
funny is most of y'all are just pundits
you know
who live in nice neighborhoods gated
neighborhoods and gated neighborhoods
you don't really see i thought biden did
a good job i think he's done a good job
so far that's fine that's that's totally
respectful okay and i think
his state of union was great
and i am absolutely prepared to vote for
a democrat
in 2024. i don't know if the san antonio
troll is serious about that but okay i
mean who's going because from rochester
come on where are we kidding here having
said all that
you complain about biden one of your
bringing energy production back to the
united states
whereas you don't see that it hurts the
working these gas prices hurt the
average person now this is where the
troll goes off the rails
i did not criticize joe biden wanting to
bring energy production domestically to
be honest i don't even know if joe biden
mentioned that
what i
spoke about was joe biden offhandedly
saying we're gonna build
and manufacture everything here in the
u.s and buy american and as i've said
before when donald trump has said things
like this as i said before when barack
obama said things like this the kind of
um
casual nature with which elected
officials say this ignores the reality
that our economy is based on not making
stuff here
we have decided implicitly through our
decisions about trade and regulation
over the last 20 to 30 years that we
prefer as a country i'm not saying you
or i prefer it but we prefer as a
country to have lower prices on stuff
and to make it abroad
and so when politicians they all do it
they say we're gonna bring every we're
gonna make everything here
it could take decades or longer to
reconstruct the supply chains
domestically to do that number one and
number two everything would get way more
expensive so when the san antonio troll
says i was against biden doing domestic
energy but i don't remember biden even
talking about that i was talking about
manufacturing domestically not gas
not gas so again troll criticize someone
who said it it wasn't me we don't have a
bottomless bank account like you do
another elites where you can just catch
an uber ride everywhere you go
so we feel it at the pump and we are
i've been i've been
all over the gas price thing and i've
been saying this is not 15 cents per
gallon we're talking about impactful
amounts of money now so i don't know
this guy must have me confused with
someone else maybe alex jones was saying
this stuff i don't know the majority
voted this is why
he's biden has to do this or he's
definitely going to lose
and i you just don't see that you see oh
we need to be
complete green energy because you drive
a car that you know not all of us can
afford that dude you have to
see it from the poor man's perspective i
i genuinely don't know what he's talking
about i did
i i haven't i don't know what commentary
of mine this is even of reference to not
even the poor man just a working class
and it's something i think you have
lived in this you know
wealthy liberal
you know wealthy neoliberal bubble for
so long oh give me a break dude yeah go
go talk to someone who said this stuff
so there's the san antonio troll um i i
am still holding out hope that someday
someday i believe it will happen
the san antonio troll will call
and actually address something i've said
as opposed to something he attributes to
me that i've never actually talked about
a florida senator rick scott's tax plan
is under fire and it should be and we're
going to talk about it on today's bonus
show
a few months ago couple months ago i
told you about the first successful
pig heart transplant into a human
sadly
the recipient an american man
has died and we're going to talk about
what this means for this particular
medical technology
what happened it is sad but we're gonna
follow up on the story and the final
remaining american mask mandate is in
hawaii
and that will be lifted in 16 days on
march 26th we will talk about
now with state mandates
uh
all going away
which municipalities are maintaining
masking requirements if any
and we'll talk about masks all of those
story or as marjorie taylor green likes
to say we will talk about mask on the
bonus show all of those stories and more
i will be joined by producer pat on the
bonus show you can sign up at join
joinpackman.com it is a great place to
sign up i believe the normal membership
prices are perfect
but
you can get a discount using the coupon
code wow 22. now just remember
you will be adversarial to alex jones if
you sign up as a member alex jones
doesn't like the bonus show oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad he's against it
i am very much for the bonus show sign
up at joinpakman.com i'll see you then